[Music]
B
I've had two comedy heroes in my life
nor McDonald and Nick
depalo Nick depalo everybody Nick depalo
up for Nick depalo
Nicko Nick
[Applause]
Theo holy now in every industry there's
often uh a person who people think is
the man right the person who gets the
accolades or the push as it's called in
some entertainment Industries and then
behind the scenes there's there's the
guy in the world of stand-up comedy for
decades that guy is Nick doollo Nick
doollo is not only one of the longest
standing veterans in the industry he's
the guy who some of the world's most
famous comedians still call when they
need help writing jokes to this day oh
we have a videotape of trump saying he
likes to grab but Hillary
doesn't Africa's given some good Ebola
AIDS lsharon all the things in life that
I love Nick defal has always reviled the
left political correctness or what we
know today is cancel culture he was
cancelled fired really before that term
exists from his own radio show at
SiriusXM when a latinx professor at
Fresno State was Joy tweeting that
Barbara Bush had died Nick depalo did
what he does best he wrote this tweet in
response dear future School shooters
please confine yourselves to college
campuses specifically faculty lounges at
Berkeley Fresno State it was funny then
and it's funny now now and he was fired
and he never ched I told her I thought
you should bleach her she agreed and
threw a cup of Clorox in my
face going on TV now you know who you
came to see that's right sir Don't Clap
you couldn't even think that joke up in
a million years I had a great time I
can't thank you people enough for coming
out iing love you thank you so much
let's do it again what do you say
huh it may not mean nothing to y'all but
understand nothing was done for me so I
don't plan on stopping at
all my is forever my Ever Getting hits
bigger than
all Big T just can't keep up with me I
just love watching him
fall no CL is forever he hey got M Club
in the building ain't no question who
about to trigger I only have good
streams big Fame big names I get more
clicks in one night than in your week's
game we go hard no fall like your ra TS
CNN plus didn't even make it through
spring we've all seen your story no
glory quom groping inters you could call
it statuto when my knee blew up didn't
stop nothing for me old man new dad
Crowder what nothing it's super sad you
two give me no love in you would think I
had traps like for Rock's husband why
they always got to screw me when they
really doesn't got that noty Bell
working no it fing doesn't we're led by
such fing losers m going to kick you in
your ass pooper trade the sulex just to
get the moment back remember we had the
lips rabbit like a dog pack follow the
tards it'll turn you to a maniac forget
fuing Hollywood they can't even act pull
the wrong pronouns out how damn they
snap been working for this forever try
to pry it back ha it may not mean
nothing to y'all but understand nothing
was done for me so I don't stopping it
all my is
forever getting bigger than
all big Tech just can't keep up with me
I just love watching and
fall my CL is
[Music]
forever okay hello it's the cobbert no
jokes clapter never ending crap like a
bow at Olive Gardens laughter's not the
target appeasing violent markets like
steel with the pecker when he sees it
got a scar Kimel never stops crying like
a tiny to living in his gated Mansion
Bing about the cops so M crocodile tears
bit he needs a mop but what did he cry
for painted his face my mind's fine even
when the time seem dark W on my side you
don't want to hear that thing talk let
the king talk stream and Rumble go and
click it now we got a whole team so we
all can kick it it's like Texas in the
middle of the summer it's hotter than in
Hell left this needs a must
umbrella don't wake the sleeping Giants
election season about to be your
mothering
blood may not yall but understand
nothing was done for me so I don't plan
on stopping at
all CL is forever Never Ever Getting
hits bigger than
all big Tech just keep up with me I just
loveing and
fall no Club is forever
mind there they go packing theaters as
we come to spit the jokes nuts they go
triggering leftist anyone know where to
score some C some blow
colan n i i a cut huh hey yeah I'm I'm
going to let you finish
but N I can't let him finish we got
[Music]
[Applause]
h
[Music]
what I
know had a fever dream last night this
is the peak fever
I have a fever like 102 you guys
remember that that Vietnamese uh Korean
Korean Mariah Cary karaoke artist touch
my body on the floor I'll be all up on
you treat me like a fever
like that's why I fear not the Asians so
today we have a lot on the show we have
Carrie Lake on the show today let's
bring up let's bring up the top sheet
just so we have this week in Biden we
have some media Mal practice at play
from the New York Post um which we'll
get into and of course this is a big
Dynamic right now is uh Governor Abbott
he's a wheelchair guy taking on the feds
at the border also really uh he's he's
he's wreaking havoc he's taking his
revenge on
trees it's not all trees but it really
is a dynamic of when people say hey
what's the legitimate purview of federal
government if you are right if you're um
you're talking about federalism versus
statism or socialism I know people hear
Federalists and they don't but if you're
a federalist and you believe in limited
federal government is there a role for
the federal government that is
appropriate of course what is that role
we always try and make it pretty clear
certainly secure borders uh would be one
so my question yeah oh there you go you
already put up comment is if the federal
government refuses to do its job do you
think that states have a moral and
ethical not only right obligation to
take matters into their own hands so
we'll be talking about that and uh
hopefully my voice sounds a little more
sexy now at some point today I'm going
to start talking breathlessly like a fat
guy cuz I can't breathe through my nose
I notic I was I was talking with a
lawyer last night in the phone and I I
was like yeah she's like are you okay
I'm like I just went up the stairs and I
can't breathe and I'm
talking CEO number two Captain Morgan
how are you I'm doing well sir I I mean
I was going to ask you how you're doing
but you already told us so that's fine I
just I just want you to get better it's
on the way it's just it's a fever and
stuff so I have to stay away from people
I don't want to be contagious how did
you how did you like forever it's it's
fine and then spine I love it what are
you talking about and then in third
chair when you hear this couple things
May 11th count bayy centered Red Bank
New Jersey go and see him because this
is I mean he's the funniest stand up
he's the funniest man alive and then mug
Club right now if you haven't signed up
yet you get tonight 8:00 p.m. this
special tribute the catalog of the best
of Nick doollo it lives nowhere else
outside of mug Club right now and
eventually we'll release some of it I
think on Rumble but right now mug Club
it's a love letter to you you get to see
what he's all about it is the OG Nick
deala how are you uh very good thank you
and thank you for doing that seriously I
apprciate unb it's I know it goes to
picking bits and I just could never do
it it's tough It's T you put a gun to
our head and said if you don't do I'm
not coming back that's not my style
you hooked your nipples up to car
batteries true um well done thank you
and then uh Nick has a funny we we'll
get into it later not so funny story
about escorted from his favorite
establishment
physically you know what we'll we'll
ease into it but if he seems like he's
in a bad mood rightfully so rightfully
so he almost fought a black guy but
yesterday Joe Biden boy you know how to
tease it had nothing to do with color
well I've been told that just ask gay
William ended up that way so yesterday
former Vice President Joe Biden respect
the office he uh spoke at a rally that
was kind of Senator on abortion and he
had some pretty harsh words for Donald
Trump but of course some fantastic
supportive words uh for women because he
likes those mhm if they're young enough
so that brings us to another installment
of this week in Biden if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me Trump and you ain't black we'll teach
Donald Trump an valuable lesson don't
mess with the women of America unless
you want to get the
benefit look if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
Trump and you ain't black I love how he
always says look and that doesn't help
it only makes it worse look at me it's a
marker to dig here if you missed the
other part of the speech before look
you're like he said look I'm going back
yes
exactly so funny I like even if he had
strung that sentence together in an
intelligible way don't mess with the
women of this country unless you want to
get the benefit is what he actually said
so that's why I continually mess with
them I like women benefits I don't
understand the admonition like not to
mess with them I'm I I just I don't
understand yeah where you going Joe
Don't Mess don't mess with the Don't
Mess put in the 401K unless you want to
get the more out of it
well I guess I'll do that no look I did
look it's a 6% match
so hit the like button if you can't wait
to see President Donald Trump and former
Vice President Biden go head tohe head
that is just I just it's something I'm
really looking forward this is going to
be a lot of fun can you imagine if he
does that in the debate like Trump would
be ready to pounce live look gross what
about to say Nick Biden's so full of
he's the only president that ends
every sentence with no joke yeah I know
everybody you know thinks you got to be
joking you're out of your mind
no joke it's like a car mechanic he like
look I'm going to be honest with you
you're like I know that means you're not
exactly it's the first I'm about to get
screwed so look let me tell you the
truth your business is always welcome
here Nick at your favorite drinking
establishment yeah he hold on before we
it's a little bit of a crazy uh morning
here U Josh firin obviously who's who's
here fulltime does anyone know where
yeah I I think he he might got in a car
wreck it was he on his way still suck in
traffic
[Applause]
yeah in the world is
[Music]
[Applause]
JS cops ination so your
pops
[Applause]
[Music]
Jos oh he got he got Halloween
toe I don't I don't know who hit him
nobody it's just it just happened aags
you ever you ever had an airbag go off
no they hurt have you have you had an
airbag go off no but I heard they hurt
oh my gosh me and Johnny Boy it happened
in an old Jeep these were these were not
friendly airbags these were airbags with
a point to prove and we were both face
our faces were burned we were both
unconscious haven't people been killed
by those things yes yeah they just go
off sometimes where do I got one
um honey um by the way hey if at some
point today we will have Carri Lake on
if you're watching on YouTube head on
over to rumble please because there's a
lot of stuff that can't actually be
broadcast on YouTube so if any point
today you see
this it just means go to rumble we're
not going to self-censor but we are
going to try and uh you know make sure
that our channels on YouTube aren't
permanently removed okay anything else
media Mal practice let's talk about it
let's talk about something
important New York Post no I thought you
said important is everyone here all but
one I'm going anyway
so this you know the Legacy Media
they're constantly messing up and I hate
to even use the term Legacy because they
have none but um we always want to
highlight it so that you can see the
slight of hand that takes place so it's
time for this week's installment of
minum M
[Music]
practice I I always love seeing that CNN
lady with the hairy forearms in
there that was a woman she's a babe the
one who has a Harry forums I don't know
her name Caitlyn Collins Caitlyn Collins
she Ruth she has hary fors
Wolf Man Silverman all right so um let's
set this up for you yesterday the New
York Post they ran an article titled a
whopping one-third of genz Shoppers
admit they prefer self-checkout kiosks
so they can shoplift okay so a couple
jenz or Jay-Z
[Music]
well I don't think they have self check
out and try Becca that was a home run
now I'm shop right next to the Nero Ah
Ah Ah that's his thing a a I love that
song though I absolutely love this right
Welcome to New York only now you have to
step over the hobo yeah let's
rewrite them oh we have one we have one
we want to we we'll put you in Alicia
Keys
wig put put me in her oh come on now oh
stop you obviously have not seen recent
Alicia Keys but right Gerald is like
merln Olson father their time is
undefeated so here's the thing uh let me
ask you where you think this segment is
going probably
not I want to clarify something a lot of
people on the right they'll give credit
where it's not due like the New York
Post for example they have been
incredibly left for a very long time
they are unbelievably biased you see
what they're doing right now trying to
prop up Nikki Haley and a lot of
conservatives think that New York Post
is an ally because of the hunter Biden
Story look that was a scoop that they
had to run and then of course they had
to make hay with it that does not mean
that the New York Post has your back
so here gen Z these Shoppers prefer
self-checkout kiosks so they can
shoplift okay the article contained a
photo of exactly one human being okay
right here we're blurring it out so uh
let let's let's take a poll here a
little bit of time if you're in mug Club
chat what kind of person do you all
think the New York Post chose to
represent the shoplifting take
[Music]
us
wrong oh my God and by the way I really
just thought it was going to be a white
guy and that would be offensive enough I
did too and she's not even gen Z it's an
older Asian lady she could be 80 for all
we know but she's clearly at least
Millennial probably Gen X yeah she's
probably listening to Pearl Jam
on
so she what that does though is the next
time a black guy knocks an old Asian
lady out see it's sort of like comment
exactly that's what they do uplifting
these are the real so let me just give
you some brief crime because I and Nick
depalo has had some bits about this so
this is right up his alley but let's
give you some 2022 crime stats okay
larsy and this is you know largely theft
in case you guys don't know Lars not
necessarily the grand variety so who
makes up uh who makes up the demographic
as far as larsy in the United States uh
White people 43% okay with 863 th000
black people 28% it's 133% of the
population Asian people
88 let me go to robbery really quick
wait AE point8 as far as ly or the the
percentage of the percentage of of
Larsen that is committed by Asians is 8%
unbelievable or as the New York Post
says the lead the only one it's always
that chines sky in the boat with the
girls and the bikinis at
he's the he he's responsible for most
yes exactly he's the one who just gets a
r off at
Walgreens so robbery okay white people
28% 55,000 black people 57% 110,000
Asians
7% now there's some more numbers here
that matter women commit about 39% of
larne offenses that means that if you
add all of this up a whopping
3% of of thievery crimes are committed
by people who look like this.
3%
3% how is that not discrimination you
had to seek this picture out and that
woman wasn't even doing
anything think of if I was that I'd be
super unless she was committing a crime
she should sue the New York
Post it's still better than putting a
white guy up there I mean I don't know
I'm just saying the beat would take it
lately yeah that's true uh in context
although in New York the Asians have
taken their fair share oh boy they and
they stop Asian hate let's show you a
criminal she was actually I bet I bet
you she rounded up for the starving kids
yeah
exactly now here's some of the other
articles by the way at New York Post
just as misleading here's one uh a
recent study that showed Gen X fathers
are more involved with their kids than
any previous
generation come on now now here's my on
audio that won't make at all not at all
let me ask you which Legacy Media Outlet
do you think is the worst out there okay
and this is an important when you do
this and you don't make people aware of
reality in other words you don't
acknowledge crime statistics especially
in places like New York with the
basically no cash bail and catch and
release and of course this has resulted
in actual people being victimized
violently from a huge portion of
asian-americans in New York to Rick
Moranis remember that mhm when you lie
about it when you try and create these
or protect certain victim classes you
create actual victims and this is just
like what Nick has brought up you look
at these stats it's not even close how
many more times are you going to have to
see an article like this or another home
security or alarm commercial with a
white guy who breaks in your home when
did
you would simply say protecting your
home is a snap protection against
burglary easy fire that kind of security
can really let you relax Dad I'm trying
to relax
[Music]
here yeah that's what we fear what I got
a ring what are we supposed to do well
tell you what I
do I'd start running let maybe now
gentlemen hustle go
go if I were you I would turn around
yeah in fact if I were you I'd turn
around and go home cuz this can only end
badly for
you don't even try
it that's what I thought ADT and I am
always there look here's the thing let's
just be honest about you'll oh that's
racist yeah where where would we be able
to pull out these statistics hey black
people watching right now comment how
often are you afraid that white people
are going to break into your house in a
black neighborhood how often does that
how often do you run into that
occurrence let's be really clear about
this I would get it if it's every now
and then when was the last time you saw
someone who was black who was a someone
who actually made up the crime
statistics as far as these violent
breaking you know the George Floyd types
actually repres we want equal
representation just not with the
criminals it seems like the most obvious
point to make but it's like no do you
think they picked on the Asian because
they're like they won't say anything
about this they're like they're not
going to start do anything have to take
it even a step further first of all the
criminals are white but the guy
protecting the nice white Suburban house
is a black dude right yes that it's you
know it's one thing to but to make it
the exact opposite I know not every time
I hear people already my head
but to it's like they're rubbing your
nose in it look at the big black first
of all to make that real he should have
been in the kitchen already that white
guy came into that was their house he's
got no shirt on the girl white guy's
girlfriend has a
fat
[Music]
hit the dump button done with those
YouTubers hey Nick tell everyone why
you're so mad guys look tell everyone
why you're so upset what went down last
night I just didn't sleep well that's
got nothing to do with the incident last
who hurt you yeah Nick who hurt you I'm
just saying uh if you're in the uh
Plano give me another T on his Dallas
Houston there there's a bunch of them
yeah if you go a union beer be careful
CU I've uh I've got food poisoning three
times at the union bear and I walked by
the kitchen there was the weirdest smell
coming out I don't know if it was the
chefs or they might have skinned a goat
back there and left it behind the
refrigerator for a year and I had the
shits again last night so Union bear
sort of near Granite Park that one is uh
be careful I I three times I Dr a lot
there but three times I've had the Foot
Right Through Me and I I don't know
what's going on yeah all right that's
why I'm a little cranky yeah I know
sorry it's you know hopefully it's just
a 24-hour bug yes that was um yeah
Dropped In My Soup
yes by some disgruntled person who
doesn't care for the people who lean
right in their politics oh it's just a
theory okay well you know what yeah I
I'll I'll get more out later we'll talk
which by the way hey you can join mug
club for $9 a month right now you go mug
list but you get it for $9 a month if
you want to try it of course if you
actually join mug club uh annually with
$89 you get the handed hand painted mug
and you get Nick Apollo special today
today on mug Club only all right let's
uh go to uh Greg Abbott who's taking on
the feds and he's a wheelchair guy so
yes again my question can't push him
around to you yeah you
can that's exactly what you can do as
long as there's somebody sliced his
tires last night
well he was rubbing it in their faces
you don't get white walls we all know
you're
wealthy I just wondered which one of
them was going to hit it out of the park
you ever seen when he gives a good
speech he does
Donuts he just Parks against and burn
while he's getting Applause he does
Donuts like a you know like a nasc carg
he does a burn you don't need the
Hydraulics I said
DHS yeah low
rider we out
Snoop ah
crippled and just to be clear all pretty
big fans of Greg evely he has won me
over I never knew a couple years ago I
was no pun attendant on the fence uh
seriously but now I mean at least with
this you know immigration he I mean
he plays hard yeah he does he does play
hard ball you know what it directly
affects this is a guy this is what
Governors are for that's right you can
cut he needs to represent the people of
his state right he should have more
power than the president as far as
serving the people of his State you can
hit the like button share if you agree I
understand a lot of Libertarians out
there they believe in such limited
government that they don't think the
Border issue is one where it's
appropriate for the federal government
to step in I completely disagree because
it affects all citizens of this country
however if you are a border state as
Texas is I think you're well within your
right to take take things into your own
hands so we have a basically a
constitutional crisis uh taking place in
Texas so Greg Abbott Governor Wich guy
he defied the Supreme Court and will not
allow border patrol to remove the razor
wire they put up Razer wire and uh then
the Supreme Court said oh you can't uh
you can't stop them uh cutting it down
sorry he put up let me just be really
clear Governor Abbott said all right
we're going to put up some razor wire
here because we have a border crisis and
you're not doing anything about it then
you had border of Patrol cutting the
razor wire off Greg Abbott Su said no no
we're not going to do that got punted
Supreme Court said ah hold on a second
actually they can still continue to cut
the razor wire until this case you know
is seen to the end and that's also a
problem because you're supposed to have
your right to a speedy trial that does
not take place in this country it puts
this uh Biden Administration in a
serious bind so let me kind of give you
the ins and outs here uh and why I hope
that other states follow suit this is a
good exam this is a good example when
you say what can people do well
Governors can do this and you can hold
your elected officials accountable
because they are there to serve you so
despite a 5 to4 Supreme Court ruling
right against the state of Texas Greg
Abbott is going to continue we have a
clip fortifying the southern border the
very latest on the border right now the
crisis in a standoff over the use of
razor wire today new video shows even
more razor wire being put in along a
contest SE of the US border this is
happening even after the Supreme Court
on Monday voted to let Federal border
control agents remove all of that wire
the razor wire was installed as part of
Texas governor Greg Abbott's security
initiative at the border known as
operation Lone Star the B Administration
arguing now the razor wire prevents
border patrol Agents from doing their
job now just to be fair before we move
on in the spirit of full disclosure some
detractors have a point in pointing out
they have a legitimate criticism that
this may just be another Ploy by big
Bick so that's something that you know
look hey everyone stands to
profit
but two things can be true that is true
yeah got to make some money and secure
the border at the same time I'd love
that his his stance was like gosh I
can't say those words I love that his
position unintended sorry his wheelie
his whe his position is basically like
all right you can cut it we're just
going to keep adding it like you didn't
say anything there's nothing in the rule
book about adding more razor wire like I
just love that he's like it's a big
middle fingure needs more razor
wies I got first blade lifts the lifts
the whisker the second one cuts the
Immigrant throat yes
exactly fewer strokes this is the
Colombian necktie
version so uh yesterday afternoon and
today is uh Thursday uh wait Thursday or
Wednesday Wednesday Thursday Thursday
Abbott uh declared the state under
Invasion invoking Texas's constitutional
right to defend itself let me read this
for you it says the failure of the Biden
Administration to fulfill the duties
imposed by that was his wheel I saw to
fulfill the duties imposed by Artic by
article 4 section 4 has triggered
Article 1 Section 10 Clause 3 which
reserves to the state the right to
self-defense for these reasons I have
already declared an invasion under
Article 1 Section 10 Clause 3 to invoke
Texas's constitutional authority to
defend and protect itself Netflix has uh
already secured a documentary the rights
and The Works we've obtained an early
copy of the poster I would see
that he's like
trees
in a Brier patch that's a bush I
don't it's gonna fall on
somebody love Dr Mexican stole my hub
caps you didn't need
Spinners so in the statement Abbott also
referenced Alexander Hamilton who
specifically foresaw these you know the
dangers of a rogue president and I know
you're thinking L the gay play no so
actual Hamilton said if the federal
government should overpass the just
bounds of its Authority and make a
tyrannical use of its powers the people
must take such measures to address the
injury done to the Constitution as as
the E this is one of those words going
to be exigency may suggest and Prudence
justify still winded because I can't
breathe through my nose so let me be
clear about this uh this is and all
references are available at lth
credit.com Link in the description this
is what the invasion as it's described
currently in Texas looks
like
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Jo interesting in that last uh uh a
picture there there was something
impeding their progress in at breaking
the law Simply Safe no no a wall it
seems like it was doing its job in one
frame they were sitting by the said wall
that was keeping them from breaking the
law and entering the uh the United
States illegally and another one they're
walking down to see where the wall stops
exctly so they come across to enter the
United States illegally and by the way
just remember last month we broke an
alltime record with over 300,000
encounters that doesn't mean that
300,000 people tried to get into the
United States and did it successfully
just encounters it's a multiple of that
that are actually getting through how in
the world can he say
you can't put razor wire because it
keeps us from being able to do our job
no the razor wire in fact does your job
it's like the automatic checkout Kos let
me let me be reductive here because this
does matter there are more slaves than
ever on earth right than ever in
recorded history we've talked about this
a lot of them are sex slaves hundreds of
thousands of sex slaves being
transported across the border we have a
piece coming up next week specifically
as it relates to the Communist Chinese
party using the open borders there is no
doubt about that so razor wire deterrent
as you see the these folks are trying to
avoid a wall let alone if they get up
there and they see a few Bick risers are
going to try and take another take
another uh direction or sex slaves drug
cartels human trafficking you do have a
choice I know it sucks to look at razor
wire that looks like a bat Boomerang but
you go hey it it stops people from
transporting sex slaves across the
border it stops uh it stops these
coyotes from stealing children from
their parents this is a choice that you
have to make having an open border and
not enforcing it is supremely immoral
I'm sorry do not let the left take the
moral High Ground anymore they have it
absolutely nowhere let me give you a
quick rundown of this so you understand
the timeline okay the Supreme Court
ruling so Texas this is what happened
they sued to stop the border patrol
Agents from cutting their razor wire
they said we're putting up razor wire
border patrol said can't do that cut it
Texas sued said no no you can't cut down
our razor wire fifth circuit agreed said
hey border patrol agents you can't cut
the razor wire then the DHS appealed it
right went to the Supreme Court Supreme
Court said that hey border patrol you
can cut the wire while this case is
still pending now keep in mind still
pending remember this is what happened
when Biden uh he knew it was
unconstitutional we had student loan
forgiveness and then we had uh um rent
forgiveness like yeah I know the Supreme
Court's going to strike it down in a few
months but for now well guess what
happens in that period of a few months
land owners landlord mom and pop
landlords who own a few properties
they're underwater and they lose their
properties because other people don't
have to pay rent that's what happens
there are real victims real consequences
the good news is as as that case was
pending Black Rock and Vanguard are
quick to scoop them all up so this is an
abuse of the legal system just like we
saw with January 6th people who were
imprisoned for years when they were not
convicted at the end of the well as long
as this is pending how long will this be
pending and that means the Supreme Court
says yeah yeah yeah you you can keep
cutting the razor wire so Texas is left
exposed yeah oh you're raping a woman no
but she consented well we don't know
that yet you keep going until we figure
it out exactly yes keep going good it's
uh and they know that and that's why
they do it right obviously it's an abuse
of the system it absolutely is and and
it's something that's used quite a bit
actually you have a lot of lawyers a big
part of their their techniques are just
just kick it punt it let's get some kind
of an extension this happens
all road just think of what they've done
with Donald Trump yeah they've changed
statutes of limitations so that they
could go after and then extend by the
way what they do with Hunter Biden so
that it doesn't come into I don't know
maybe midterm primaries this is the kind
of stuff that they do there are many
tools at their disposal so when people
talk about a rigged system you're not
just talking about voting machines this
is one that is important um there's also
a lot of precedent for this by the way
as far as defying the courts when you're
talking about a tyrannical government
and Gerald you're obviously the resident
historian and this is this is more about
you know it's defying the courts but
it's also defying the federal government
if they are overreaching into states
rights like legitimate territory so 1832
Worchester versus Georgia yes not Wisher
close the case was centered on Georgia's
right to make laws regarding kind of
tribal land I think it was a Cherokee
Nation that they were talking about
inside there and Governor Wilson uh
lumpin uh governor of Georgia he refused
citing Federal overreach saying you guys
can't tell us what to do here and the
case is where president Jackson's quote
supposedly came from John Marshall has
made his decision now let him enforce it
now what I what I really want to
highlight in these two examples is that
this is an extreme measure this is
something that highlights a tension that
is going on around the country not just
a specific State doing this and we'll
get into how this impacts Texas in a
second this was right before succession
like this was when people were talking
about it and it was just another example
of the federal government telling States
what they can do and saying you know
what we're not going to do our job we're
going to reach until you had to do your
job by the way and it pisses people off
the other one in 1963 University of
Alabama by the way the secession
movement in the South started like that
same year yeah it was that same year
same happened right so 1963 University
of Alabama desegregation kind of this
famous case where JFK federalized the
National Guard remember that federalize
the National Guard you might hear that
for Texas to stop Alabama Governor
George Wallace from preventing
desegregation at the University of
Alabama and here's the the famous clip
from that
yes the consequences of your stand must
rest with you the choice is yours I
would ask you once again to responsibly
step aside and if you do
not I'm going to assure you that the
orders of those courts will be enforced
why is a police officer in a hard hat
well you never know you don't really see
that very often do you no it's it's
protective gear it's a helmet they
didn't have you know as good helmets
back back then so they look like hard
hats do you know what happened later
that year anybody noticed the date June
they replaced it with a police
hat June 23rd 1963 what happened JFK was
shot later that year so it's and I'm not
tying these two things together
necessarily what I'm saying is there is
a big kind of movement of people
frustrated at the federal government
yeah for either overreaching or not
doing their job the way that they should
yeah and that it's a big deal what's
going on in Texas right now this may be
one of the biggest things that happens
for States right because of some of the
other support that that you've got
obviously coming in for the State of
Texas from all over the country I think
we're at the point where yeah go Nick
isn't there a 10th Amendment is that the
federalism thing we have the
responsibilities of yeah I mean there
get picked up by the states
right being mentioned well the federal
government is supposed to in in a
statement from one of the supporters
here Ron D santis from florid right
we'll get to it in a second but in his
statement he's basically saying like
they never would have signed on to join
the union if this was not there we will
protect our borders invades you're
coming to our def if you don't have
borders you don't have a union and this
is look comment I do think that at some
point in our lifetime we are headed for
some kind of national divorce or some
kind of civil yeah I I think it CU look
let's let's be honest here your tax
dollars right now your tax dollars
you're in Texas you're in the State of
Florida end up going to pay for crap in
Cal in San Francisco in California that
you don't support you have nothing to do
with and those people actively fight
against you we don't share the same
fundamental values anymore we really
don't we're really at the point where it
doesn't make sense especially if they're
not even going to protect the borders
what kind of a union do you have
genuinely curious if you think for the
first time I Believe In Our Lifetime we
headed for that I think we definitely
are headed for that and you did a change
my mind on this I don't know when you
did it but I'm actually I'm wearing the
shirt secure our border changed my mind
go get it at Crowder shop you say our
border secure our bordera
Shakira if you have any doubt about the
importance of securing the Border go
watch that change my mind
watch you talking people this laying the
for why
aary and saying you have a b doesn't
really mean you have a border right
doesn't do anything to just draw a line
in the sand and not defend it right I I
use that change my mind thinging it's
up my
marriage secure
that change my mind yeah you
should she makes a really crappy BLT and
you're like well you changed my mind
yeah you Chang my mind your mind a
gripper
[Laughter]
you're gross you're gross that's about
how it goes so we also have by the way a
lot of Republican support uh which is
often surprising because it's like the
world's biggest high school so the
people who backed uh Abbott who's a
wheelchair guy you have Glenn yunen from
Virginia you have Brian Kemp from
Georgia but then you also have Ron D
santis chrisy Nome Mike Johnson um and
of course oh this also surprised me
former uh South Carolina Governor Nikki
Haley had this to say I told them that
if they would do this that South
Carolina would wrap their arms around
them and take care of them I now
officially work for you there is nothing
that you can need that we won't make
sure that we deliver sorry right
clip China's throwing people at us left
and right you'll hear more about that
soon is that a Chinese flag that's a
Chinese flag and uh I wish the yellow
SAR is a little more prominent in that
shot yeah there and then she looks She's
like isn't there supposed to be another
flag oh no it's just the Chinese flag oh
me
all
go bind your feet
you B Nick rubs off go shoplift yes yes
go yeah shouldn't you be ripping off a
pack of pork chops at
public
claming I don't know they do a lot of
pork that's funny oh sorry no I had
nothing I'm just saying the Asians
contribute so much
to putting them making them to be Thief
we don't let him into Harvard it's I
mean I'm not a big the Chinese I know
they're buying up land that the
asian-americans who are here do a lot
she wants the Communists no I understand
she works for them yeah which would
almost mean she's a
communist yeah that's the whole idea I
think Nikki Haley is a communist yeah
she is change my mind change my
mind no it's not gonna I I don't do it
if I I know that in good faith you
cannot change my mind n she doesn't have
a red dot she has a yellow star right
yes she
doesy guy and size two feet
I don't know why that culture can
someone out there Chinese Amer like when
did that become sexy to them why sex I
like a girl feet it's endured
lifelong pain from breaking her toes and
her foot on slowly you don't like a girl
with a big bunet and up her feet
look like Jurassic Park feet those are
sexy I love
it Jurassic par I love it it's a raptor
yeah yeah you know like Twisted TOs and
no well you know what I don't know
you know what the truth is I'm making a
judgment and I've never spent time
around it it may be one of those things
that hey I shouldn't take off the table
because I may really like it go to any
podiatrist Ronnie sit in the waiting
room for a few minutes be fine that's
what fil feet the women that came
in uh look up this handle footbinding
was viewed as a right of passage for
young girls and was believed to be
preparation for puberty puberty
menstration and child birth oh oh go no
stop it symbolized a girl's willingness
to obey just as it limited the mobility
and power of females kept women
subordinate to men hold on hold on time
out you think we need a leg up men yeah
like physically over women oh man if we
don't like break their feet when they're
young they're going to just run right
over us yeah I guess that's what like
from Street Fighter the Chinese I'm
that's why she could kick so fast right
all men listening go out the next time
you buy buy him four sizes too small
let's get a whole national no no you got
to do it you got to do it slowly so even
notice it's like half each time and you
keep
doing and then she gets pregnant it's
like the Grinch's
heart so back to the constitutionality
but if you have small feet send
picturesle and by we still do have this
has been going on what is it the uh the
w win a date with stepen Crowder right
at some point yeah that's still going on
date Step at lc.com yeah I want to see
this I've never list uh you know list
your uh your likes dislikes I don't love
long walks in the beach I just have to
warn you but we'll go through
submissions at some point oh there we go
that's nice who's the little girl no
that was uh was like an 11-year-old what
are you Biden well she is size two feet
so I don't care it's Kate BOS and why
she oh that was BOS staring up at the
truth is it was ruined for me Kate
Bosworth was adorable until I saw the
flipper she was walking I like what are
those
skis got one different colored eye he
have no humanized
feet you're way over the hill all right
back to the constitutionality here
Article 1 Section 10 clause three of the
Constitution we have Carri Lake coming
up in a little bit if she hopefully it's
watching uh and it says no State shall
without the consent of Congress lay any
duty of tonnage keep troops or ships of
war in times of Peace enter into any
agreement or compact with another state
or with a foreign power or engage in war
unless actually invaded or in such
imminent danger as it will not admit of
DeLay So I theoretically it means that
the states can now assist Texas with the
illegal Crossing that means Arizona can
say hold my hold my whatever it is
tequila what do they drink therea
tequila
tequil mcow all right that's true they
do have how dare you go with like the
basic response it's 99 Cents it's 99
Cents and you know what it it doesn't
Faire badly Arizona IC tea whatever it
still holds up I'm just saying it still
holds up Nick I did that to make you
sound funny Joe go ahead thank
you it's going to take more than that
Nick work like a charm so other states
can say hey you know what Texas we're
going to throw in and you know what it
would make sense for States to do that
if they need to protect their borders
because if Texas does it and the next
state over doesn't do it guess what you
still don't have a border so we have to
force New Mexico to put up yeah and we
have this too as far president in
Arizona versus the United States Scalia
acknowledged that article one provides
here's a quote for the states Sovereign
interest in protecting their borders so
here
is where I find this gets interesting it
kind of puts a former Vice President
Biden in a corner and a question to you
is what do you think the Biden
Administration does here um really there
are kind of two options I would say and
I'm sure there's a door number three and
you'll say it's binary thinking
yeah 2 a 2 a ex so option one is uh the
bid Administration they can basically do
nothing they can basically do nothing
until this goes yeah well this will make
them look like the you knowy wet
that they are option two would be send
in the troops to arrest Abbott and of
course that would actually put Biden in
a situation where he looks like someone
trying to directly Aid in illegal
immigration to the United States which
is not necessarily better there re it
really kind of is a no- win situation
all that was required was someone to
take action in this case a wheelchair
guy and now you end up where Biden uh is
really kind of in a bind so if he does
that by the way we also do have some uh
AI predictive technology they've
simulated what the arrest of Greg Abbott
may look like tell me what the hell's
going on here I'll tell you what's going
on you call me face I shot the
place up I know you didn't call
me AB doesn't play he does not play
around let me give you the 2A right oh
my God so two is that he gets arrested
right so obviously right there he would
uh he would do his best to to roll away
but nonetheless if unsuccessful they
could federalize the National Guard or
the the the troops here in Texas they
could federalize like they did in
Alabama right um and if they do that to
the Texas clar people tuning in who's
they yeah who's
the federal government federalizes the
it sound like you're saying abot Federal
so that's Joe Biden can do that and come
in and say no no no you you work for me
now right basically like I'm the captain
so he he comes in and does that he's
actually I me that is probably the most
incendiary thing that you can do which
is why I think that that one big example
that we have is is the only one that I
can think of I'm sure that there may be
potentially another example out there
but if you do that you're not just for
open borders you're willing to start a
war with a state essentially right
because you're for open borders because
you want to be able to cut down the
razor wire that is protecting the Border
it doesn't give him any good outs but
this is serious yeah because it's
something that you know Republicans are
talking about right now Donald Trump
says that Republicans shouldn't try to
solve this problem before the election I
I don't think the Republicans could ever
don't think you have to I don't think
you have to send that memo president
Trump what I do think they need to do
though is actually when they get into
power do do something now executive
order build the wall what is it 11
billion to20 billion on the high side of
it we can do that NPR 11 billion we had
an old report the most generous I
believe was from NBC or ABC we'll make
all the references available you can go
check the change of my mind it was like
20 billion 150 billion plus is what it
cost taxpayers every year not to mention
the crime and uh if if you don't have a
board you don't have a country remember
that standoff with the cattle ranchers
or something we're that close to setting
off a civil war we really are I mean uh
that that was the same deal right the
feds was saying you can't do this on
that property and land rights and the
mineral rights it was a little more
convoluted this is about yeah citizens
period who just want to be able to live
in a state where they feel protected I
mean imagine living uh in in southern
Texas here if you're living in that area
you're living on the border the the
crime there is unbelievable it's rampant
and they'll try and tell you actually
immigrants these are these are the lies
that they'll use we've gone through this
in it changed my mind and this doesn't
necessarily uh address the moral
imperative uh for a nation to protect
its borders they'll say actually
immigrants here are far more likely to
obey the law no that's not true talking
about legal immigrants because it's
really hard to figure out what kinds of
crimes illegal immigrants are committing
and when you actually try and uh you try
and control for illegal immigrants which
is very hard to do it's many many
multiples more as far as them being
likely to commit a crime outside of the
crime of coming here illegally and that
affects people generally speaking in
impoverished neighborhoods often legal
immigrants who live in this neighborhood
uh these neighborhoods quite a bit so
they'll use that argument and then
they'll try and say oh hold on don't you
have a heart What About dreamers they
don't believe in deporting illegal
immigrants who are literally in prison
right now it's not about dreamers oh
hold on hold on a second you know these
people are just seeking a better life
they're seeking Asylum they're not
seeking Asylum they're coming from
countries that simply suck they don't
have good economic opportunities they're
not being persecuted for their religion
they're not being persecuted for their
point of view they are just coming here
for Economic Opportunity and this of
course all this facilitates an
environment where we have more slaves on
Earth than ever in recorded history we
need to be very very clear about that
there's compassion do you think that
theast majority of people com over right
now families justek a life that's not
what's happening you are you are
breeding exploitation and when that is
the environment of course you end up
attracting more criminals which is what
we see everywhere that we have porous
borders none of that
matters in the sense that it's all a m
point if you just agree that it's a
nation's job to protect the nation yeah
this would qualify we know the body
Administration and people like them hate
this place M and they're hellbent on it
and they didn't even have to hide it
right they said we want you know we're
going to fill this place with people
from third world holes we're going
to have all the bootes for the next
whatever I mean this is this is been uh
in play this plan for a long time and
it's finally coming to fruition right
and we're standing around with a thumbs
up our asses going oh is that uh is that
the federal job or is that the I mean
Jesus and then they they want to do
everything they can to suppress
Cubans yeah like yeah we we want all not
the people who really really hate
communism you know whose dad was
arrested because he played the
saxophone
yeah I thought when you show those clips
of The Border there I thought there was
the opening of the New York Marathon
that's what it look like exactly 70,000
different ethnicities was World War Z
like where the people are trying to get
into this like but there's there's a
wall there I think so that that would be
that helps it and Carri is coming on
here in just a in just a minute but I I
think you can't score the point that you
made enough this is allowing all of the
worst forms of crime and debauchery and
exploitation that you can think of the
human trafficking side the fentanyl that
is killing people left and right in this
country the ability for people to come
in and have child sex slaves the ability
for people to come in and be taken
advantage of even if there's no slavery
at that point they're just taken
advantage of because they don't get to
use the system and so they can't report
a crime when it happens to them they
can't report a boss that says you know
what I'm keeping half your paycheck
sorry about that do you want a job
tomorrow I got 50 other people standing
in line it allows for all of that
exactly right it allows for all of that
and all you have to do a very simple
thing is close the border and then guess
what you can do you can put the
resources that used to go to cutting
razor wire because that's how you secure
the Border apparently you can put it
into the processing of people who come
here legally because right now five 10
years down the line I don't even want
legal immigrant
enough what do you think is would you
rather be tripped up in razor wire or
barbed wire what do you think wor Barbed
I would rather be Barbed you'd rather be
Barb 100% Barbed why 100% why cuz I've
been in barbed haven't been in razor
Razer sounds bad yeah Razer would be
Barbed you in barbed wire I've gotten
caught in barbed wire haven't we all
boys wait how did this happen Mr man who
hasn't cast the first stone yeah what
were you
do how you get abouts how'd you get and
meshed in barbed wire tell me you got
that I think a girl had a restrain water
against exactly my buddy had a my buddy
had a r that was like 30 minutes away we
we'd go out there and ride horses like
thech of Mr and girls they were ladies
and they had barbed wire and so
occasionally you know you're like on the
fence line or something like that and
you get nicked by it or you know you
well nicked by it is not getting
entangled in it well I wasn't crawling
into another country and I was hoping
that you were riding a horse and didn't
realize a perimeter just got
CL barb wire have you seen my barbed
wire like you know scarf is there much
of a difference do you have a barbed
wire scar you don't no Barbed wires it's
just it's supposed to stay in you though
right and razor wies are supposed to cut
you razor wire just slices you to pieces
barbed wire like you get caught on and
Barb Wire is more Pokey razor is more
slicey I don't know what's worse have
people comment well throw it to a pole
comment I really don't know barbed wire
is dirtier I feel like you'd get tetanus
from bar yeah you definitely get tetanus
you're not going to get it from
something slicing into you it's
dirtier it's like it's like a fishing
this is your issue cleaner it's like a
fishing lure that bar Bo is filthy yeah
I'm going the r I'm bleeding out right
now but I going to have tetanus I'm
never eating here
again CLE your barbed wire I have
standards that's what you do with what I
see what are you doing with what I don't
see this barbed wire is disgusting uh
and then if you're poor you just break
glass on the top of the fence right
that's what I've heard yeah you just put
it up there and GL you just break some
glass the problem is you don't really it
doesn't really it's not a deterrent
because people don't see it well that's
even better they go to climb the they
already oh that's dirty pool and then is
done oh this is broken Dirty Glass so I
guess it's just one of those things that
you do just you know so deep down yeah
you kind of just can picture the smile
here's an idea um we have weapons
flamethrowers yeah I'm dead serious I
don't get have you ever seen Congo
something along those I I laugh even
when Trump was for the wall and stuff I
went along because I love Trump and
stuff but I I just laugh at the concept
of a wall if you're really serious about
keeping
[Music]
people
that mines in a perimeter because of
Cubans trying to get into Guantanamo so
we we do it at GMO well I don't know if
they still have landmines but I do know
that they have all kinds of razor wire
fences because Cubans would rather be in
Guantanamo Bay prison than actually live
out there in Cuba I've been there did
Uso show oh yeah yeah there's that one
there's that one place where they have
the uh was it the not the pot pie or the
pot roast yeah yeah yeah it's a lot and
then there's
aasb sounds amazing that's what I'm just
saying it's like a pub but their pot
roast is good oh okay got yes yeah
sunsets beaches yeah honestly did you do
the Mongolian Barbecue night you do it
with the officers and they go out there
in the big drum no no we didn't oh no
anyway it's a fun gig it's a fun gig get
we did a sock cop thing it's very gig
yes well you know out there with the
Navy so all right hey look we do have uh
her here as a guest but I want to give
you an update we talked about this
yesterday so um then after our show
yesterday right now it's 10:05 Central
God's time so 11:05 Eastern Satan's time
and we played the audio for you but uh
after we played the audio on the show uh
dwit right the um the Arizona Republican
chair Jeff dwit resigned from his
position so really quickly before we
bring her on let me play the audio one
more time after this audio the man
resigned let's hit play and then bring
on our lovely guest so what do they want
what do they want me to do you want to
stay out for two
years but let tell you what I can offer
you
but um I said she can do whatever she
wants talking head this
so the ask of me was it's kind of funny
so the ask I got today from Back East
was
has do there any companies out there or
something that could just put her on the
payroll and give her to keep her out and
I
said what are you willing to do whatever
we need to do this is about defeating
Trump and I think that's a bad bad thing
for our country is there a number at
which I can be bought not be bought
that's what it's about you can take a
pause for a couple years no they go
right back to where you're done M
no 10 million 20 million 30 no no no a
billion
no this is not about money this is about
our country there you go that is a bad
lady in a good way please welcome car
[Music]
Lake and you can follow her at car Lake
on X and uh I mean just support her
everywhere Miss oh Mrs Lake yes yes you
are on by the way while we were getting
ready I saw you I saw you put the powder
on I love how uh it's okay but tried to
make myself look a little better here it
early it made zero difference I mean
that in the best way you you already
looked fine and you did this I'm like
she looks the same she just you just
wake up like this no I made a huge
difference I had a little too much blush
on one side and I was like okay I'm
going to just fix that right now oh
blush is a cruel mistress I know that
too so Carrie Lake first off where's the
best place for people right now to
support you because I know you have a
lot going on on the show many times
thanks for asking uh car lake.com k a r
i l a ke.com and you can find out where
I stand on all the issues what my plans
are I want to go to Washington DC and
and help drain the swamp and you can
tell there's a big swamp there and and
and get some of these great policies
that um we saw under President Trump get
them solidified into law so we don't
have to worry about another Joe Biden
coming in and destroying our country
well okay and I want to get to that
because obviously we're going to be
talking about the 20 24 Senate race and
I don't really talk politics so much on
the show and really this is more of a
cultural issue and it's it's it's a
symptom of something that we see at
large both in conservative media and
with these Republican packs I said this
yesterday and I would if I'm incorrect
you tell me you know this is recorded
this made it out so this is a Shakedown
let's be clear this was a Shakedown and
often when people hear about a Shakedown
as we just did yesterday with DT who
resigned um it's the last Shakedown that
someone was willing to possibly endure
and you had had enough I'm willing to
bet this is not the first time something
like this has happened or someone has
approached you like this
correct um not like that that was kind
of extra special I guess you could say I
have had other things where you just go
wow this is just a slimy disgusting
World politics is I came from journalism
and that's pretty you know pretty
corrupt as well it's propaganda so I've
had other other things happen in
politics where I just look at my husband
or one of my team members and go can you
believe that but this one to be honest I
hadn't even relistened to this um since
since it happened something struck me
this week I just got the the the feels
and I went I want to I want to listen to
that again and I dug it out and I put it
I played it we were at the dinner table
and I said I just want to hear that how
that conversation went down again and my
daughter she's 20 she was sitting there
and we played it and we were just
shocked right I I remembered it I've
described it I've talked about it in
speeches but hearing it again and my
daughter looked at me and said Mom what
are you going to do about that she said
does that guy still have a job with the
Republican party and I said yeah he
still runs the Arizona GOP she says he's
unethical he's ter that's terrible mom
and so I had that my daughter's guilt on
me right and um that's one of the
reasons that that that is out now can I
ask you um first off were you were you
the one recording when that took place
yes I was recording I I'd got I'd gotten
a call I was home it was was back in um
I think it was the last day of February
the first day of March okay of last year
and I'd gotten a call from from Jeff and
he said hey um I'm I'm real close to
your house I'm like right outside your
neighborhood I got to come over you you
round and I said I'm really busy right
now to be honest I've got I'm writing my
finishing my book I'm packing for CPAC
and he goes it'll just be real short
five five 10 minutes doesn't get the
message Jeff sounds like
him I said Jeff um if this is about
talking me out of running for Senate
because some other people that in in
kind of his Circle have been trying to
talk me out of running for Senate I'm
not really interested and he said well
no no no no no I I just it'll be five
minutes but I can't talk to you about
what I have to say it can't be done on
the phone I have to do it in person
which is always like a big red flag that
goes up right it's like what so I
thought well maybe there's going to be a
threat I I just didn't know what to
expect so I I've just clipped on a
little microphone and invited him into
my home and uh he sat at my my dining
room table and and that's what
transpired and and I was really shocked
I was
absolutely I was horrified at the time
I'm like is this really happening this
is you know am I on Candid Camera what's
going on here right um but it wasn't
until I relistened to it you know 11
months later just earlier in the week in
front of my daughter and she heard it
and my husband heard it and we went oh
my gosh this is this is absolutely
bribery this is
bribery yeah it's not only bribery it's
it's uh it's combined with intimidation
you know when someone is saying well a
lot of these people would like it if you
you know stepped back and so in one hand
you know you could have some money or on
the other hand you now know that there
are these powerful people who really
don't want you popping your head up and
uh it's almost like they're trying to
give you a choice while letting you know
that you have no choice that's what
really bothers me well it just shows you
wonder why more good people don't get
into politics if this is happening to
everybody who dares to step foot in
politics this is why there's very few
people and this is why they hate Trump I
know you guys don't want to get
political but Washington Washington DC
hates Donald Trump I want to send people
to Washington DC that Washington DC
hates you know this in this uh audio
recording you heard about the backs
scratching club I'm not going to join
the back scratching club right I'm going
to join the ass kicking Club okay yes
and and we're not going to be scratching
backs and they already they already
don't want me that's fine the people do
right and we need to get some people who
are in in DC who are actually going to
do as our founding fathers envisioned
and work for We the People yes and you
know what this is a big problem no when
I say you know they're important
cultural tians just because people
sometimes don't think about
micropolitics and how it affects them
you know this also happens we've talked
about this in conservative media when
you're talking about these packs right
these are 501 C4s a lot of these
entities out there have 501 c3s and
there are a few key donors across the
board in the Republican side of the
movement and that's why so many
candidates look the same I mean you were
there when you know uh did stand up at
the the Arizona I don't I don't know if
it was the Federal theater you saw how
many people were there and that is not
something that uh any politician or any
pack would like to see happen right they
would say this is this is far too
rambunctious this is far too edgy but
guess what the people do and it's a real
problem because I've never so in doing
all of those shows and you were there
I've never once in my life met a Lindsey
Graham fan a Mitch McConnell fan a Paul
Ryan fan a Mitt Romney fan ever I've met
plenty of Carri Lake fans I've met
plenty of Donald Trump fans and yes
Ronda santz f but the truth is these
candidates all look the same because
there are a few key people who pick them
and the same thing often happens in
media it happens in media too where it
becomes very monotonous and uh it seems
to me like you ran into um this sort of
well they tried to Stonewall you and you
exposed what was happening in media even
in alternative media yeah you're going
to go work for this group or this
conglomerate you know we're starting to
get alternative media that's kind of
growing and becoming bigger and you're
going to have to push kind of their line
right and what they want and you lose
your freedoms when you do that but but
you know this just goes to show you how
deep the corruption in DC Is We I don't
know somebody said who was it back East
who are these people I've thought about
it i' I've come up with people it could
be but the sad thing is it could
literally be hundreds of people or
entities right and most people don't
have the uh ability a lot of these
politicians maybe they don't have the
megaphone that I have where they can say
look what just happened right yeah they
just don't have the ability well then
what they'll do is attack the messenger
right and they'll say oh I can't believe
she would record him that was a private
conversation rather than addressing the
content so I'm glad that he resigned
that's good he's gone now um and I would
assume that he obviously this is did he
admit did he fully admit that it was the
direct result of this or did he just try
and do it quietly not acknowledge it I
don't know he wrote a two-page diet
tribe that I tried to get through and I
was like you know where where is the I'm
sorry I shouldn't have done that Arizona
I'm going to work to make amends and
make this better and I I I'm resigning
because we need the Republican party to
be strong in this most pivotal year
going into the 2024 election where we
either keep our Republic or lose it yeah
and I'm I am u i be he behaved
unethically he didn't mention that he
tried to say like this is a normal
conversation be between friends Stephen
I have a lot of friends yeah I've never
had a conversation or this is a normal
business
conversation uh how many of you out
there work for a business or run a
business where this would be acceptable
conversation yeah also he's I'm willing
to bet he's not a friend that's
something else will say right we're
friends I can't believe you I'm on about
you and Jeff Jeff DWI not friends no um
after this happened I was I was just I
was shocked it was like oh my gosh I
can't believe it and him acting like it
didn't happen and just like oh hey how
you doing I'm like dude do you not
remember do you not remember that
conversation at my dining room table get
away from me yeah I know plus he's a
he's just I just think I think he's a
wiener all right let me ask you this
what are your plans for the
2024 uh I know there's a senate race
obviously we're talking about nationally
a lot of people are talking about Donald
Trump's VP pick your name has been
thrown around what are you thinking what
is Carrie Lake going to be doing I'm I'm
thinking about our country right now I'm
I'm really it weighs very heavy on my
heart of how we get through this very
tumultuous year and and if we can
survive on the other side of it and so I
think the best place for me is the US
Senate frankly you know we got to get
the US Senate in the hands of the
Republicans we can't have Chuck Schumer
in charge of the Senate and president
president Trump in the White House we've
got to have um some backup for him there
so he can get his judicial picks his
Supreme Court picks his cabinet picks
and we have a great opportunity in
Arizona to take back the senate seat
from um a liberal who's who's uh sitting
in that seat right now so I think this
is really a great opportunity think the
country needs to make sure that we have
a strong Senate the Senate is very
important and I I think that's a great
fit for me I see myself standing on the
senate floor on inauguration day in in
January of 2025 and and working for the
people standing on a Jeff thewit skin
rug that's that's a figurative that's a
joke people okay just toy that'd be
pretty slimy I might slip and fall on
that
one like Home Alone Senate uh and I know
you're B let me ask you one thing though
because some people say Obviously with
your last election uh how confident are
you that the election interference the
shenanigans that took place in the last
election that you encountered that those
won't take place when you run for office
again because you have a lot of people
out there who I don't want to say
they're I don't think they're being defe
if they look at what happened with you
they look at what happened with Donald
Trump and they go yeah but maybe it
doesn't matter if we vote anyway because
look at what they pulled well this is
why they don't like populists you know
they've been messing with elections
forever and when you get a populist on
the ticket like Donald Trump you know if
you get the two Mambi pamies like you
described and then the result is 51 to
49 you go well okay they were both kind
of when you get a populist like Trump
who's filling stadiums and the people
are for him and they're flying Trump
flags on their on their trucks and they
were doing the same with our race for
governor flying carry Lake flags and
showing up in huge numbers then when
they skew the election and mess with it
nobody believes it that's why they hate
populace so um we haven't fixed it
you're right we haven't fixed it and
unfortunately the people who've taken
over our government here are a bunch of
um you know corrupt people as well but
we're we're making uh what we've done is
we we've educated the public as to what
they're doing so they got to come up
with new each time and I think they're
really they're worried about how they're
going to cheat or rig the next election
because that's why they're trying to
lock Trump up that's why they're coming
after me right the people who ran the
election government official suing me
now for defamation for exposing how they
rigged our election right I mean they
want to silence us they want to scare us
they want to make us penniless and
destitute and um I I'm just I'm not
going to shut my mouth when there's
wrongdoing in our country so we're going
to keep moving moving forward every day
we just pray to God you know use us
today the way you see fit and we are all
yours and we want to help help uh take
this country back well I appreciate I I
want less shutting of your mouth but
more of Nikki Haley someone duct taped
that shut uh Carrie like thank you so
much we always love having you here I
know you have other things to go on too
thank you for taking the time all right
thank you Stephen God bless you be well
this has been car
[Music]
Lake I have an idea what I have an idea
I wanted to tell but we'll tell her
offline here so uh pops Crowder make
sure you get this to her um I would like
we can do this or she can do this we can
send back scratchers to all of Congress
that say scratch your own damn back
courtesy of Cary Lake I think that would
be a pretty good a pretty good thing to
do you you always had a calling as a
noble te sales I did
yes he's got he's an idea man he's an
idea man well they said not to self call
Star kiss had a couple more things we'll
talk about it after all right well you
know what maybe we won't so hey
if you want to uh join M club we
actually uh we were going to have car
Lake but I know that we went over time
so um we'll have her on another time uh
we're going to do it's chat Thursday on
mug club which is where we just rapid
fire take as much of your chat as
possible and of course if you join mug
Club right now you can go mugas for $9 a
month but you know you join annually you
get the mug you actually become a part
of the club and that's what supports
everything that we do here the
investigative journalism and putting
together you know a special like Nick
depalo which is exclusive to mug Club
starting tonight so
YouTube uh I don't know why you're still
here you can click that button if you're
on Rumble and continue watching thank
you Rumble YouTube does anyone want to
say
it piss
off look a lot of work goes into this we
couldn't do it without you mug Club $89
annually if you aren't subscribed I just
want to take a moment to
say Joe Biden does not care about black
people
[Applause]
[Music]
what